and speaking of people i'm not a fan of
uh let's finish up with what's going on
in canada because obviously this story
is not going anywhere and i think one of
the things that justin trudeau is really
going to prey on right now is that the
media will just move on the worldwide
media which has basically ignored what's
happening up there or when they do cover
it we've shown you some of the stuff
from cnn and msnbc they basically mock
the people who are protesting
peacefully and fighting for their rights
in an honest way the way you're supposed
to do it in a free society i think
trudeau now that he's ramped up all of
these emergency powers he's hoping that
you know some other stories will happen
maybe maybe we could get a war in
ukraine or something and people will
stop paying attention um but
it is ramping up in canada that is the
simple truth they are literally i saw a
video this morning they are have police
going out in ottawa handing out flyers
to people saying that you will be
arrested or fined if you're out on the
streets right now we covered already uh
this insanity related to how they will
look into the people who donated to some
of the crowd funding that was supporting
the truckers i mean it's really nuts
stuff and now here is one of justin
trudeau's ministers
talking about how they will target trump
supporters what look you've just
compared people who may have donated to
this to the same people who are funding
maybe a terrorist i just want to be
clear here sir this is really important
a lot of folks says look i just don't
like your vaccine mandates and i donated
to this now it's illegal should i be
worried that the bank can freeze my
account what's your answer to that
well if i think if you if you are a
member
of you know a pro-trump movement who's
donating hundreds of thousands of
dollars and millions of dollars to this
kind of thing
then you ought to be worried
did you catch that
did you catch that these are bad people
we live in a time where the people who
pretend to be the good people are the
bad people
um you're allowed to do with your money
what you see fit most of the people
first off what's he talking about the
people if you're a member of a trump
movement who donated hundreds of
thousands or millions of dollars what is
he talking about this was all completely
grassroots now there may be somebody who
is a big trump supporter who donated a
bunch of money but that we know that
there were thousands and thousands of
people who were throwing in 25 bucks 50
bucks just to support these people not
to support violence not to support
racism just to support people's right to
fight for what they believe in and do it
peacefully and that's exactly what they
were doing and now and now trudeau and
this clown these are the people that are
escalating this nonsense uh but the way
they link it you see what they're doing
they're linking it to something having
to do with trump and they're gonna
somehow try to link it so that the
people who are the truckers that they're
the racists and that's sort of like the
racists that support trump and january
sixth inter insurrection and trucker
insurrection like you can see how the
machine morphs ah it's evil but i admire
it's evil i don't admire it's evil i
admire the way it does it like the
disgusting way it does it right in front
of our faces and we always have to react
to it like you got to give the devil his
due on that right this thing is evil it
does it right in front of us
but finally what might be happening up
in canada is that their conservative
party which basically has been a liberal
party they've got a liberal party and a
conservative party they're very very
similar they also have the people's
party of canada which is sort of their
libertarian party led by maxine bernier
who uh i just taped an interview with
we're going to put up tomorrow that's
sort of the more real libertarian like
government get out of my way party but
in essence they've had this liberal
party that trudeau is the head of and
they have the conservative party they
don't have much difference the
conservative party pretty much just bows
to the liberal party um but finally it
does seem that the conservative party
might
be
getting some balls they might just be
ready to stand up to this guy we've
mentioned how a couple of the premieres
and some of the provinces they are not
going to listen to trudeau they're
they're pushing against uh these
emergency powers well yesterday a jewish
conservative and you'll see why i
mentioned that she's jewish a jewish
conservative member of parliament
started going after trudeau and just
listen just listen to the way he
dismissed her hopeful vision for public
life isn't a naive dream it could be a
powerful force for change if canadians
are to trust their government their
government needs to trust canadians
those are the words of the prime
minister in 2015.
these people very often misogynistic
racist women haters science deniers the
fringe same prime minister six years
later as he fans the flames of an
unjustified national emergency so mr
speaker when did the prime minister lose
his way when did it happen
honorable prime minister
mr speaker
conservative party members can stand
with people who wave swastikas they can
stand with people who wave the
confederate flag
we will choose to stand with canadians
who deserve to be able to get to their
jobs to be able to get their lives back
these illegal protests need to stop and
they will mr speaker
[Applause]
justin trudeau is an evil soulless
lizard person there is nothing real
about that cardboard cutout of a human
being
she's using his words against him now
she happens to be jewish from what i
understand she lost family members in
the holocaust okay and then he dares say
that oh you stand with people who wave
swastikas and and stand for the
confederate flag which by the way where
are all the videos on that
can we get some of them i'll play them
phoenix i want you to do a dive tomorrow
like you've never done before i want
every single swastika
every single confederate flag every
single mean sign i'm a mean man and i'm
out here protesting for freedom with the
truckers supposedly there was one and it
is very unclear whether it was planted
or not and one bad apple doesn't ruin
the bunch there have been thousands if
not hundreds of thousands of protesters
out there but all trudeau has
is you guys are racists you guys are
nazis you're homophobes and transphobes
and islamophobes and phobiaphobes and
enough is enough so finally
finally the conservative party and their
leader of the conservative party we've
played some clips of her candace bergin
not candice bergen
american tv star candice bergin from
murphy brown a different candace bergen
but it would be funny if it was her uh a
different candasbergen like they're
actually kind of lining up and they're
saying we are going to fight this
insanity but trudeau's got nothing now
and what what happens
what happens to someone who has no
principles what happens to someone who
comes in preaching
rainbows and diversity and all of that
nonsense when when they have painted
themselves into a corner because he did
this to himself it did not have to be
this way